did you see his face he was wearing some
sort of mask
who do you think's this next victim
let's go save the flash
[Music]
flash on the Tuesday November 13th on
the CW everybody is Charlie we got a new
flash trailer to break down in just a
heads up it's gonna be on break for the
next two weeks when it comes back I
think that it'll be more in sync with
the timeline of arrow then there
shouldn't be any more breaks between
that and the end of the crossover the
crossover is gonna be episode 9 which is
usually the mid-season finale that'll be
happening mid December this year we've
also got another preview of black
costumes Superman and what he might be
doing during the crossover so I'll talk
about that at the end of the video too
there's a new brand of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave up related
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this obviously big
thing is that they're introducing the
ragdoll character from the comics it
seems like they're going with the second
version of the character just because
that's the one that most people know
when they talk about ragdoll from the
comics he's actually peter merkel jr he
took the mantle from his father if they
turn it into this big father-son thing
where he was never able to impress his
father or live up to his legacy as
ragdoll so because there's all that
family drama happening right now maybe
they'll try to play that angle a little
bit but the description of the episode
reads Nora let something slip about the
future it devastates iris Barry has to
take down ragdoll and Caitlin learned
something about her future so in order
of black big plot beats Nora
probably tells iris that Barry dies
during crisis on Infinite Earths
and she's a single mother trying to
raise Nora in the future there's really
the only thing aside from telling her
that Joe West and maybe Cecile wind up
dying in the future too because she
seems really close to Papa Joe so maybe
he's just like a really awesome grandpa
to her in the future and he dies and it
devastates her the thing Caitlin learns
about her father might have something to
do with the research that he was
conducting that led to his disappearance
and one of the big reasons they might
have for only surfacing the character
now like why did he wait till now to
make himself known if he's been alive
this whole time it might have something
to do with collateral damage from the
thinker's Dark Matter satellite but
there is an episode title of the Iceman
Cometh that's coming up so that's
probably the first real big appearance
that he gets I didn't talk too much
about it during my episode video just
because I wanted to keep it from
getting too long but the end tag seen
with cicada clutching his chest like
he's in pain but suddenly finding
himself way stronger just makes it seem
like he's evolving because of the
accident with the thinker satellite so
what probably happened is is the
satellite broke apart shrapnel hit him
that shrapnel that he pulled out of
himself was the speedforce dagger that
he's been wielding all season long if
you haven't seen it up close it says
star labs on the dagger so it's
literally a piece of the satellite that
was embedded in him infested in with
that special tech that gives him the
connection to the dagger and is also
tangentially giving him powers
fundamentally changing him on a genetic
level which is probably what causes him
to be so crazy in the future
he's probably evolving into an
all-powerful villain later in the
timeline so like 30-plus years in the
future just imagine how much worse his
condition gets it probably spreads all
over his body making him way too strong
for any member of team flash or the
Justice League to take down which
sidebar also creates the circumstances
in which iris would think it'd be okay
to hide Nora's metahuman powers because
the future cicada is running around
still killing metas and iris has already
lost Barry to crisis on Infinite Earths
she probably freaks and is worried the
cicada will come for Nora if she turns
into another flash like Barry that's
probably the reason future iris put that
dampening chip inside Nora when she was
a small child there were a lot of you
that were also wondering about the
legends of tomorrow's re timeline
because metahumans were outlawed where
she comes from in the time period that
she's from is close to the time period
that Nora came back from but one of the
problems with that is that legends of
tomorrow doesn't really care about
keeping things Canon within the
arrowverse like they just have a
completely crazy storyline and they
don't worry too much about it tying in
with what's happening on the other TV
shows so usually when I'm thinking about
future plot on the flash I try to just
keep it within the things that they've
teased on the flash TV show so we just
implied that cicada is the whole reason
for this dampening chip situation and I
know a lot of people have asked about
the 2056 Barry message from legends of
tomorrow
like I said legends of tomorrow is
really bad
about keeping things Canon with the rest
of the air overs future Barry's message
was more of a tie-in with the season
three sabotage storyline where saboteur
was going all over the timeline fooling
people into believing that he was the
original meta like he went way back in
the timeline and started to create those
acolytes but they didn't push too much
into that cult based storyline so Sava
tar was just manipulating the timeline
jumping all over the place so I think
there was a version of Barry in an
alternate timeline in the future that
was trying to warn people in the past
don't trust anyone that looks like me
because he was trying to tell them that
he was sabotage or one of his time
remnants was sabotage
so just assume that when they resolved
their sabotage storyline and got rid of
him it sort of cleaned up any of that
because Barry is supposed to die during
crisis on Infinite Earths way before
that 2056 date so it wouldn't make sense
in this current timeline for him to
exist in 2056 but no worries if you have
any questions about weird continuity
errors like that feel free to ask me
sometimes they're easy to explain
sometimes not so much like sometimes
they're teasing something that they'll
pay off later and sometimes it's just
part of a storyline that they decided
that didn't like after it was done so
they want to sweep it under the rug and
hope that the fans don't remember about
it
we got a slightly better look at the
crossover this is black costumes
Superman looking like he's going to town
on all of the heroes so it looks like
them doing their version of the Superman
fight during Justice League this might
be based on the original Zack Snyder
Superman's story line during Justice
League before he left the project
originally went Justice League was going
to be two movies Superman was gonna come
back and be kind of evil for most of the
first movie but because they collapsed
it and it was only one movie they cut
out the black costume scene like there
was an actual Justice League deleted
scene where Superman is looking at his
costumes and he almost puts the black
one on that was originally gonna be a
much bigger deal during the Justice
League movie so it seems like the
arrowverse is just borrowing some of
that storyline where you have a slightly
darker version of Superman going after
all the heroes there was a bunch of
other big news lately Marvel just
confirmed they're doing a Winter Soldier
TV series spin-off from Avengers 4
during
phase four so I'll explain what's going
on with that which characters it'll
involve they said vision is gonna be a
big part of the Scarlet Witch TV series
so I'll try to talk about that during
that video
and speaking of Superman they dropped a
teaser of Henry Cavill on The Witcher TV
series so I'll try to do video for all
those things as quickly as possible no
worries congratulations - it's just
lightning you're the giveaway winner
from my last big DC video please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for my flash episode 4 video and click
here to learn why zoom is coming back
during the hundredth episode thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]